[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a escala en París una
emisión de radio Francia internacional
en colaboración con la televisión Franz
24 en español en la que cada semana
damos la palabra a personas del mundo de
las ciencias de las artes la política
los deportes y claro está de la sociedad
civil una de las formas de desigualdad
entre hombres y mujeres es la poca
participación de estas en el ámbito
Financiero en pleno Siglo 21 más de la
mitad de la población mundial debe hacer
frente a reducir las opciones para
participar de manera independiente en el
mundo de las finanzas un proyecto de
asesoría financiera con perspectiva de
género acaba de ser lanzado aquí en
Francia para precisamente garantizar esa
Independencia financiera de las mujeres
y es por eso que contamos aquí en
nuestros estudios con la presencia de
Paloma Castro directora de la empresa
Rise que busca precisamente certificar a
actores financieros y permitir que las
mujeres inviertan en este mundo de las
finanzas Paloma Castro bienvenida a esta
escala en París Muchísimas gracias Estoy
verdaderamente agradecida un con
nosotros Rey se define como una alianza
entre grupos de mujeres y actores
financieros decíamos para que las
mujeres puedan con toda confianza
invertir en el mundo de las finanzas
Cómo nació este proyecto Paloma tres fue
fue una evidencia primero porque yo soy
como mujer y como persona un poco con
interés inversora pero en la parte con
más riesgo los startups y me di cuenta
que éramos un 1% y dije Bueno pues esto
resulta que a lo mejor va a ser más
endémico de lo que pensaba y es donde
llegamos a la conclusión que solamente
18% de las mujeres invierten mientras
que los hombres es una cantidad
muchísimo mayor con lo cual las mujeres
era una evidencia no invertían con lo
cual no eran parte de la economía con lo
cual todo lo que nosotros podemos
recurrir o de una cierta manera pedir en
plan igualdad estaba reconocido
jurídicamente había un marco pero las
mujeres no eran independientes segundo
una demanda a mí
tortura está la velización este consejo
a las instituciones financieras para
poder ser un sello de confianza me lo
han pedido más de 400 mujeres ha sido
verdaderamente una voluntad y lo tercero
el mercado Cómo estáis bien sabe me lo
leo Aquí no hay negocio si no hay una
demanda y la demanda es tal Por qué
Porque si estamos hablando de la
cantidad de dinero que duerme en
las tarjetas en las cuentas corrientes
de las mujeres los las instituciones
financieras pueden tener un negocio
inminente y fantástico lo que ocurre hoy
es que hacía falta por esos dos mundos
las mujeres y el mundo de la finanzas
ahora bien A qué se refieren
concretamente Paloma cuando ustedes
están hablando de financiamiento
centrado Precisamente en las necesidades
de las mujeres cuando hablamos de
inversión lo que es súper interesante y
hemos descubierto Durante un año y medio
es que las mujeres no invierten no
consideran ahorran sobre todo pero
porque ellas no consideran que eso es
una inversión sino que el riesgo no
la confianza para las mujeres es algo
diferente está visto desde un punto
diferente y nosotros Durante un año y
medio hemos sido capaces de captar los
30 criterios que si una institución
financiera y cuando hablo de institución
financiera hablo desde un banco a un
corredor de seguridad de seguros a
gestor de finanzas
mero
interventor de cómo llega usted sus
inversiones o como ya usted lo que es la
contabilidad todo el mundo puede ser la
velizado lo que es interesante es que a
las mujeres cuando les dices
con la inflación hoy si metes todos los
días ahorro 100 euros 10 euros todos los
meses los pierdes
esta mentalidad todavía como que es un
tabú no se sabe hablar para los hombres
exactamente pero los hombres ven las
cosas diferentemente Si los hombres
invierten hoy entre un 70 y un 80%
significa que su medida de riesgo es
diferente para un hombre normalmente y
estoy haciendo un estereotipo Y lo
siento mucho el riesgo no se considera
en función de valores distintos se mira
más
en cuanto me va a producir Oye qué
interesante
estos cinco años que bien una mujer le
voy a dar tres de Los criterios que
nosotros hemos determinado con las
mujeres y con las instituciones
financieras Durante un año y medio va
siempre a mirar Bueno siempre 80% de las
15% de mujeres que invierten porque
nosotros hemos hablado con las que
invierten
las que quisieran invertir y no saben
nos dicen yo quiero hablar de mi momento
de vida A mí no me diga usted
simplemente Uy qué interesante 3% dígame
usted
qué ocurre cuando yo estoy intentando
dar la educación a mis hijos claro
como se dice no mucho más con los pies
en la tierra y lo que es interesante es
que el dinero Usted me dice movilizar el
dinero de los hombres una vez que
tengamos calabilización todo el mundo va
a mejorar la transparencia porque las
mujeres uno de Los criterios es la
transparencia o sea idealmente
invertir va a ser algo como natural como
una comoditización O sea si usted
considera que hoy con 10 euros puede
empezar a invertir
si es capaz usted de comprarse un
teléfono móvil por una cierta cantidad
usted puede invertir Paloma a este
respecto quiero que usted me dice
entonces Ok es un problema de que las
mujeres tienen poca tendencia a invertir
tienen poca confianza dijéramos así
Ahora bien quién puede invertir en este
proyecto y sobre todo Qué garantías hay
de que los recursos que la persona
invierte van a ser bien empleados y cuál
es la capacidad de recuperar en un
momento dado los beneficios de esa
inversión como cualquiera que quiere
invertir incluidas las mujeres a ver le
voy a decir nosotros lanzamos una
campaña en
colectivo crowdfunding para poder
realizar el sueño
desde ahora hasta el 15 de enero está en
la plataforma proximea y cualquier
hombre mujer toda persona que esté
interesado en cambiar y en movilizar ese
dinero puede participar o sea yo lo sigo
diciendo proximea Rise inviertan en este
cambio de mentalidad nuestra voluntad es
poder con ese dinero
movilizar todo lo que son las
instituciones financieras hacerlo de una
manera más rápida y poder autentificar
certificar y acompañar Pues nosotros
también damos consejo a las
instituciones financieras para que
puedan más y más llegar a las mujeres
Entonces cualquier persona que ponga
dinero en Rise puede empezar con 1000
euros
y tiene la garantía de hacerlo con una
estructura proximea que está cubierta
por la utilidad financiera del mercado
es aquí nosotros Qué vamos a hacer con
el dinero aparte de automatizar a mitad
del año que viene estaremos por toda
Francia tenemos 70.000 clientes posibles
estamos trabajando con el gobierno con
euronex con muchísimas instituciones
para dar la validez a este sello de
confianza Y empezamos a trabajar fuera a
nivel internacional a partir del fin del
año nuestro compromiso es que para el
2025 1% más de mujeres inviertan Cómo
son elegidas las instituciones
financieras en los bancos los corredores
los operadores de bolsa todos estos con
los que ustedes han trabajado como los
eligen sobre qué criterios algunos
criterios porque usted me habla de 30
criterios no lo vamos a enumerar todos
pero Deme dos criterios fundamentales
que puedan yo me visto de mujer y digo a
mí me interesa invertir Cómo hago muy
bien a ver para ser certificado empezar
con la auditoría dentro del dictado Rise
y el consejo de Rise normalmente va a
ser la institución financiera la que va
a venir hacia nosotros Porque para las
instituciones financieras esto es un
poco una evolución del
environment social el sg que ahora todo
el mundo tiene para estar en bolsa
entonces Una institución financiera va a
venir y va a decirme yo quiero ser
auditado yo como garantizo que las
mujeres puedan decir Guau porque los 30
criterios con los que les voy a auditar
me los han dado ellas y uno de sus
criterios por ejemplo sería han estado
ustedes calculando Cuál es la diferencia
de la masa que tienen invertida en
inversores mujeres hombres no quién está
en el consejo de administración sino
cómo están usted intentándolo otro de
Los criterios que las mujeres es muy
interesante A ver si me presenta usted
productos
yo creo que esos productos tengan más
impacto o que se pueda clarificar muy
claramente como de los cinco euros que
pongo yo dentro de cinco años Esto va a
cambiar
el clima societalmente para los niños
para educación ahora bien un informe
reciente de publicado por un periódico
especializado de finanzas aquí en
Francia hablaba de que dos de las
principales fortunas del mundo
se han centrado fundamentalmente han
tenido como objetivo los intereses de
las mujeres estamos hablando de lbmh y
estamos hablando de Channel pero más
importante ese mismo periódico decía que
los dirigentes de los diez principales
bancos de Francia todos son dirigidos
por hombre por hombres Perdón entonces a
mí lo que me dice esto más que un
problema de confianza de las mujeres es
un problema de discriminación de la
sociedad hacia las mujeres a ver le voy
a dar una pequeña idea Si usted mira la
composición
inversión en estas una charal no está no
está cotizado pero los bancos Sí y él ve
más también y mire usted el ratio de
mujeres que son inversoras pero usted
que esto también de normal que no haya
muchas mujeres dentro de las heridas de
decisión si las mujeres invierten más y
ellas van a ser parte de la economía y
como dicen todos los gobiernos lo que
hace falta es que la economía tenga el
punto de vista de las mujeres más
mujeres invirtiendo significan más poder
en general sin duda ahora para invertir
se requiere que la mujer tenga los
recursos suficientes usted me habla de
1% de la población pero no sería más
equilibrada esta situación a partir de
que se respetase el principio de a igual
trabajo igual salario le voy a decir hoy
Gracias a lo que ha sucedido en los
últimos tres años de la democratización
de la inversión con 10 euros al mes
puedes empezar a ser un inversor pero
que es más interesante es lo que me
acaba de decir una de las compañías con
las que trabajamos el año pasado gran
empresa farmacéutica Suiza fantástica
cuando lo primero que hicieron para
igualar los salarios
En cuanto la ley vino fue un 20% más de
una manera sabe Cuántas mujeres
invirtieron el dinero versus Cuántas
mujeres lo pusieron en su libreta de
ahorros Cuántos
95% de las mujeres con el 20% de
incremento lo pusieron en su libreta en
un mundo de una manera muy breve porque
se nos va el tiempo en un mundo tan
incierto como el que está hoy en día qué
tan importante o qué tan interesante
puede resultar para una mujer invertir
más que mantener una dijéramos un ahorro
que de una u otra manera le resulta
seguro le voy a decir todas las mujeres
cuando llegan a la hora de su vida
activa terminarlo un poco al retirarse
se encuentra con una disparidad de 40%
Respecto a los hombres porque porque no
han hecho más que ahorrar o ponerlo de
un lado Qué significa perder una mujer
tiene clarísimo que cuando ahorras una
parte de ello lo pierdes arriésgalo Pues
estamos ya con estas palabras llegando
al final de esta escala en París no me
queda sino agradecerle a Paloma Castro
directora de Rise su presencia en esta
escala Gracias por habernos participado
con nosotros Paloma gracias a ustedes
les damos una nueva cita aquí la próxima
semana en otra escala en París
[Música]
[Aplausos]